Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir à tous !
Canada, 1999,
pour la première fois, j’utilise
un service de voitures partagées.
Il fallait réserver par téléphone,
bien à l’avance,
il y avait des horaires fixes.
Chaque membre de l’association
de ce service partagé
avait une petite clé dans sa poche
et cette petite clé lui permettait d’aller
là où étaient les voitures stationnées
et d’ouvrir un petit boîtier.
Si tout s’était bien passé,
dans ce petit boîtier,
on pouvait retrouver la clé de la voiture
qu’on avait sélectionnée.
Je ne vous cache pas
que ce type de service
est resté très longtemps confidentiel.
Et je ne crois pas me tromper
en disant qu’aujourd’hui,
ce sont les nouvelles technologies qui
ont vraiment permis à ces services
de prendre leur essor fulgurant.
Aujourd’hui, si vous voulez utiliser
un système de voitures partagées,
il vous suffit d’avoir sur
votre application le bon service.
En quelques clics, vous faites
la réservation, le paiement -
tout cela est automatique -
vous vous dirigez vers la voiture
et d’un simple mouvement
de votre smartphone,
elle va s’ouvrir et elle va démarrer.
C’est à la fois extraordinaire
et tellement simple.
Donc, on a vraiment
une innovation sociale -
je veux partager ma voiture
ou des voitures avec mes voisins -
qui est soutenue
par de l’innovation technologique.
Et inversement, on a des innovations
technologiques, typiquement le smartphone,
les applications multimodales,
des données en temps réel, par exemple,
qui vont influencer mon comportement
et faire que
je vais plus facilement grâce à
ces applications ou ces données,
transformer ma manière de me déplacer
et combiner différents modes de transport.
Voilà un petit peu les interactions
entre cette innovation sociale
et cette innovation technologique qui sont
vraiment totalement complémentaires.
Je pense que vous avez tous une idée
de ce que c’est que l’innovation
ou les nouvelles technologies.
Je pense que vous savez aussi
ce que c’est que la mobilité.
Quand on me dit smart mobilité,
la première chose qui me vient en tête,
c’est le service de trottinettes
électriques en libre partage
ou en free floating,
comme on dit dans le jargon,
ces trottinettes qu’on peut
prendre partout dans l’espace public
et qu’on peut redéposer aussi partout.
Je me rappelle très bien la première fois
que j’ai testé ce service
de trottinette électrique.
C’était à Paris.
J’ai mis l’application sur mon téléphone.
En quelques clics,
j’ai pu repérer la trottinette
qui était près de moi dans le quartier.
Je me suis approchée et j’ai pu la
faire démarrer et profiter de Paris.
Au lieu de prendre le métro
ou de marcher -
de bêtement marcher, j’allais dire -
je me suis retrouvée les cheveux au vent
sur les quais le long de la Seine,
avec une expérience qui était vraiment
très réjouissante, très urbaine aussi,
et qui est vraiment un atout
des centres villes.
Il y avait vraiment quelque chose,
une grande liberté, je dirais,
vraiment une grande liberté.
Mais là, en fait,
j’ai changé mon comportement
dès que j’ai utilisé
cette trottinette électrique.
Mais je n’ai pas laissé ma voiture
au garage pour l’utiliser.
En fait, non,
j’ai délaissé le métro
et j’ai délaissé la marche à pied
pour utiliser une trottinette électrique.
Si on y regarde de plus près,
cette trottinette électrique
n’est pas tellement écologique,
voire pas du tout écologique.
Là, on arrive vraiment au cœur du sujet.
Est-ce que la mobilité sera
low tech ou high tech ?
Quelque part,
je n’ai pas vraiment la réponse.
Je ne suis pas futurologue.
Ce qui m’intéresse vraiment,
c’est de savoir quel type de mobilité
on veut dans nos villes dans le futur,
quelle mobilité on veut
en tant que pouvoirs publics,
et en tant que citoyens et citoyennes.
La question qui va se poser, c’est :
ces services de nouvelle mobilité sont-ils
vraiment écologiques et durables ?
Est-ce que -
Est-ce qu’ils vont avoir
un impact positif ?
Ça se traduit en termes
de mobilité urbaine.
L’Impact positif,
c’est ce fameux transfert modal.
Est-ce qu’on va avoir grâce au service
de trottinettes électriques partagées
des gens qui vont abandonner leur voiture
pour utiliser ce service-là ?
Une des dernières études récentes,
qui a été faite en France,
c’est que 44 % des gens qui ont utilisé un
service de trottinette électrique partagée
l'ont fait au détriment de la marche.
Ils auraient marché
si le service n’avait pas existé.
Comme à Paris, s’il n’y avait pas eu ce
service de trottinette, j’aurais marché.
Ça, c’est la première question.
Et la question subsidiaire, c’est :
imaginons que ces trottinettes électriques
en free floating
fassent effectivement
un transfert modal intéressant,
qu’effectivement je laisse ma voiture pour
utiliser ces trottinettes électriques.
Il faut savoir que c’est un service
avec énormément de technologie
et qui a donc un impact relativement
négatif sur l'environnement.
On va devoir mettre dans la balance :
est-ce que ce transfert modal,
positif et durable
ne va pas être compensé négativement,
j’ai envie de dire, par l’impact
négatif des trottinettes électriques ?
Ces trottinettes électriques,
on les fabrique à l’étranger, donc
on les importe, on les transporte.
Et ce sont des batteries.
Et de l’électricité, pas toujours verte.
Et il faut les gérer :
il faut les transporter
d’un endroit où elles sont trop
à un endroit où elles ne sont pas assez.
Et pour les utiliser, j’ai besoin
de toute une infrastructure,
j’ai besoin de mon téléphone,
j’ai besoin de bande passante,
d’une application, d’ordinateurs,
de serveurs, etc.
Tout ça doit être mis en place
pour que je puisse utiliser
ce service de trottinettes électriques.
Donc on réalise que c’est un impact
qui est assez négatif.
La dernière étude sur le sujet,
par exemple, une étude américaine,
nous dit que la durée de vie moyenne d’une
trottinette électrique en libre partage,
c'est 28 jours.
Ce n’est pas ce que vous aurez
si vous en achetez une, je vous rassure.
C’est vraiment le fait
qu’elle soit en libre partage,
qu’elle soit dehors tout le temps,
sous la pluie,
sous la chaleur, sous la poussière,
et elle est utilisée
par énormément de personnes
pas toujours très précautionneuses.
Il y a beaucoup de vandalisme aussi.
Et elles sont sur-utilisées.
Mais 28 jours, on sent bien que ça,
en termes d’impact environnemental,
c’est assez terrible.
Mais en conclusion, c’est ça.
Va-t-on avoir ce transfert modal
de la voiture vers les mobilités douces,
partagées, collectives ?
Et même si on a ce transfert modal
vers de la mobilité partagée,
est-ce qu’une solution high tech,
style trottinette électrique,
dans la balance vaudra mieux
qu’une solution très low tech,
comme par exemple la solution la plus low
tech qu’on connaisse : la marche à pied ?
Là, on est vraiment au cœur du sujet.
Et je vais dire en conclusion,
moi qui travaille comme smart city
manager pour la région bruxelloise,
ces questions reviennent souvent.
Parce que la smart city,
c’est de promouvoir les technologies,
c’est de promouvoir l’innovation,
c’est de promouvoir de nouveaux services
efficaces et fluides pour les citoyens.
Mais c’est aussi de promouvoir
la durabilité.
Il y a un équilibre à trouver.
Il y a une sorte de tension entre ces
deux objectifs parfois antinomiques.
Comment est-ce que je la règle
dans mon travail ?
J’utilise une sorte de mantra
qui est la première loi des technologies
de Melvin Kranzberg,
qui a écrit les six lois
de la technologie.
C’est un historien des sciences
qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur la relation entre
société et technologie.
Cette première loi
des technologies, c’est :
la technologie n’est
ni bonne ni mauvaise.
C’est vrai que la technologie
en soi n’est ni bonne ni mauvaise,
c’est l’usage qu’on en fait.
L’important est de garder son enthousiasme
pour la technologie et l’innovation
et de mettre des garde-fous.
C’est un peu la posture qu’on a pour
l’utilisation de vos données personnelles.
Avoir à utiliser des données personnelles,
ça fait de très bons services.
C’est très innovant, très créatif,
mais on ne peut pas laisser tout faire,
ce n’est pas le Far-West.
On a mis des règles très, très strictes
sur l’usage de ces données personnelles.
On balance un petit peu les deux.
Ici aussi, pour ces nouveaux
services de mobilité,
il faut mettre des garde-fous.
La deuxième partie de cette phrase -
« la technologie n’est
ni bonne ni mauvaise » -
il y a une deuxième partie qu’on oublie
parfois et qui me touche beaucoup :
la technologie n’est ni bonne ni mauvaise,
mais elle n’est pas neutre non plus.
Technologie ou pas technologie,
ou quel type de technologie,
ça reflète chaque fois
des enjeux de société importants.
Dans la smart city, tout est politique.
Donc, il faut avoir quelques points
importants à garder en tête
quand on parle de stratégie smart city,
quand on parle de nouveaux services.
Les points que je garde en tête,
ce sont les trois principaux.
Le premier, c’est de faire attention :
pour certains, la technologie,
ce n’est pas un simple outil
à notre service,
mais c’est une fin en soi.
Plus il y a de technologies, mieux c’est.
Et donc quelque part,
moi, j’essaie toujours d’avoir la posture
de mettre en priorité nos besoins,
nos problématiques.
Et on va trouver une solution.
Peut-être que cette solution
fera appel à de la technologie.
C’est vraiment d’inverser toujours
cette manière de penser.
Le deuxième point, c'est que la croissance
des services technologiques,
cela induit de la croissance économique.
Évidemment, le low tech
est beaucoup moins lucratif.
Plus on fait la promotion
de services technologiques,
plus on augmente la croissance économique,
ce qui est tout à fait
un objectif louable.
Mais de nouveau ici, on parle de mobilité,
donc il faut revenir
à nos besoins de mobilité.
Et le troisième point, c’est qu’acheter
un outil ou de la technologie,
c’est souvent la solution la plus
facile et la plus attirante, je dirais.
alors que de promouvoir et de travailler
sur des solutions plus low tech,
plus traditionnelles,
demande beaucoup de temps
et demande plus d’humilité.
J’espère que ces quelques réflexions
vous donneront du grain à moudre
pour vos propres débats intérieurs
entre la mobilité high tech
et la mobilité low tech.
En tout cas, je vous souhaite
de tester un maximum,
de combiner les différentes possibilités
de mobilité qu’offre Bruxelles,
que ce soit les trottinettes
électriques high tech
ou la marche complètement low tech.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)